shia labeouf claps back at olivia wilde
adding more behind-the-scenes drama to
her film don't worry darling welcome
everyone to entertainment tonight kevin
frazier's off today less than 48 hours
after olivia's viral interview about
harry styles her split from jason
sudeikis and claims of firing shia well
shaya just poured more fuel on this
hollywood feud
certain people on set really believed in
this
really unfair social hierarchy that was
only getting in the way of people's best
work after telling variety she fired
shaya because his combative energy came
in the way of her having a safe trusting
environment on set shia is not having it
and is providing receipts i would
consider myself an immersive actor i
hate acting because it feels like like
you can get it wrong i hate losing
you know i like to win
variety obtained text messages allegedly
sent by shia to olivia announcing his
departure from the film august 17 2020
this morning a video with the hashtag
time's up olivia leaked to twitter
allegedly shot two days later it shows
olivia seemingly begging shaya to
reconsider alluding to a conflict
between shaya and then co-star florence
pugh shayashaya
i'm not ready to give up on this yet i
think this might be a bit of a wake-up
call for miss flo if she really commits
if she really puts her her mind and
heart into it at this point
and if you guys can make peace what do
you think
is there hope
fans have noticed pew has been mostly
social media silent when it comes to
promoting don't worry darling she has
not commented to variety about their
article so why didn't shia continue on
the film in an email to olivia obtained
by variety shia tells his side quote you
and i both know i quit your film because
your actors and i couldn't find time to
rehearse adding olivia's media narrative
is attractive click bait not everyone
gets this opportunity
ultimately olivia replaced shaya with
now boyfriend harry styles who preaches
this message
[Music]
olivia has not commented and as for shia
i'd like to argue because it made me
feel like i was in power
he's more than 600 days sober and has
found faith in an interview with bishop
robert bair and shaya explained why he
converted to roman catholicism it wasn't
like i you know i willingly came in here
my life was a mess complete mess and i'd
hurt a lot of people nobody wants to
talk to me including my mother so much
of life is uncontrollable to feel and
control feels good
moving on to will smith who's been doing
some inner soul-searching after
oh wow a source tells e.t will is
regretful of what went down at the
oscars but is feeling less depressed and
ashamed i'm sorry really isn't
sufficient we're told the 53 year old
continues to work on himself but feels
more comfortable being out in public
again since apologizing within the last
week wills returned to instagram first
with a gift then with a video catching a
tarantula and now some words of
encouragement don't worry about what
people say about you they gonna just try
to do anything they trying to do to
destroy you